>> I think India can become a superpower because
it has the population
and the kind of population that would make
it one.
But you think in order for India to do that,
it's really going to have
to concentrate on education far more than
it's done in the past.
It strikes me that the education in India
has to start at the basic
level, elementary school, work its way through
the middle school and
high school.
I worry less about universities in India,
both because I think they
will and can develop faster, and because university
education for
Indians can be done off-shore.
So we just have to hope that India's education
system will equal it's
wise as a superpower.